jocelyne blouin qui est météorologiste
de son métier gecina tous les soirs en
studio avec nous afin c'était en 1978
baguette en main ghislaine blouin livre
son premier bulletin météo aux côtés de
bernard de rome véritable pionnière et
passionné de météorologie et
d'environnement c'est une des premières
femmes scientifiques qu'à présenter la
météo à la télévision comme on l'a vu un
article on ne veut pas toujours dire du
bota pendant trente trois ans à chaque
soir elle est entrée dans les foyers des
téléspectateurs canadiens qu'elle a
conquis avec son talent son enthousiasme
et son humour au fil du temps les outils
ont révolu et c'est de cette façon que
je vous ai montré la première photo
satellite
elle était vieille de six ou sept heures
et son travail aussi toutes les données
est accomplie du point de vue
température il y à un réchauffement
global c'est le plus chaud jusqu'à
maintenant une des premières à parler de
réchauffement climatique
en 2010 elle s'est rendue au groenland
pour réaliser une série de reportages
sont les effets des changements
climatiques depuis 1978 vous êtes venu
au moins quinze mille fois nous livrer
les nouvelles du siège quand une
longévité exceptionnelle
avouez le récipiendaire de nombreux prix
nationaux et internationaux elle tire sa
révérence des ondes en 2011
je suggère évoluer ce métier c'est une
nouvelle technologie en fait ce qui
s'est passé dans le domaine de la météo
puis l ag slynn l'ami celle quelques
heures sur la main qui est toujours
prête à aider à nous dépanner à nous
rendre service qui partage ses secrets
de jardinage qui partage ses meilleures
recettes
mais sa passion pour la météorologie ne
l'a jamais quitté même à la retraite en
2016 elle a créé une application qui
permet aux personnes météo-sensibles de
mieux planifier leurs journées des
maladies météo sensibles il y en a
elle aura fait bien plus que la pluie et
le beau temps et c'est jacques andré
charbonneau radio canada mon frère